emily is with us in Madison Wisconsin hi
Emily how are you oh my gosh super
excited well I'm honored how can I help
okay so long story short I'm very low
income I'm working a plan going back to
school to try and like pay my own way
but anyways I heard about a plan called
Habitat for Humanity and I went to the
implication and found out how you get an
affordable mortgage through them is they
actually need to take out two mortgages
one is called a silent mortgage and as
long as you live it you don't have to
pay it back but to me that felt kind of
like I'd be getting it I'm like a few
years away from that point but like I'd
be getting into twice as much house that
as would be wise well if you don't if
you know the habitats the vast majority
of what you owe isn't you owe nothing on
it as long as you live there as you said
so that doesn't bother me
yeah that part of the house doesn't
bother me the only part that bothers me
is the mountain you have to pay and it
sounds like right now you're not in a
position to do that right not not yet I
was you know thinking for a few years
out I know well so what are you studying
in school medical coding okay and how
old are you 27
okay and what have you been doing for a
living see I spent some time as a
student I I was working for the 8th for
a while I became a single mom three and
a half years ago and so it's been work
has been kind of difficult since then
and my daughter has special needs so she
has 40 hours a week of in-home therapy
that I now have to be present for so my
thought is I can go is going back to
school I'll graduate in a little less
than two years at which time I should be
able to get a job right away
and how are you going
job if you've got to be at home 40 hours
a week well at that point she'll be in
kindergarten and so then she'll be
getting off their therapy through the
school and so while she's in school I
could go to work but in the interim I
have to be home and I don't want to be
at home doing nothing I want to be
moving my life forward so okay I need to
think about a habitat house you don't
need to think about a house you need to
rent as cheaply as you can or stay
somewhere with family free until you get
through this storm that you're in which
is finishing school and being available
for her and the other thing the only
thing that is available to you is while
you're doing school and while you're
doing the therapies at home as you said
you have to be there but maybe there's a
side hustle you can develop to do
something from home can you do the
country can you do the coding at home
yes I'm yeah that's an option so why
will it take you two years to finish
that well I have to get through all the
school work first I have to graduate I
figured their credentials and then I can
start the medical coding this cool work
your GED no I don't require four year
degree it doesn't require four year
degree being medically to do medical
coding
I know it's less than two years of
college so like I may require two years
of college to do medical coding it can
be condensed into ten months but I was
planning on doing it on a part-time test
because my learning disability is so
that I can like get through it
oh you and you have a learning
disability I do as well yes Gord usually
takes me at least twice as long as the
odd fridge very good okay that makes
more sense than two and a half years to
do medical coding which usually does
take less than a year okay that's fine
yeah all right then you've got you've
got a game plan but let's just take the
house off the table and not worry about
that let's work it we'll worry about
your your child and your career track
for now and then once you get the career
going and you get her into kindergarten
then we can start talking about neck
steps towards being debt-free building
an emergency fund towards you know
buying a home at that point and maybe
then habitat comes into play maybe it
doesn't
maybe you just save up your money and
buy a house that maybe what you're able
to do if you can make enough coding and
and if you can get where you can do
something from home while you're doing
this schooling and not delay your degree
not delay your certification then I
would if you could find anything that
you can do from home to earn some extra
money a side hustle and that kind of a
thing will help you so hey good luck
with it if I can help you further you
call me anytime sounds like you got your
plate full kiddo